OK, let's have a conversation about a possible
treatment for some corona virus patients.
I really want to do this carefully because
unfortunately, thanks to Donald Trump, this
is being propagandized incorrectly by both
sides.
People on both sides of the political spectrum.
And the truth is that almost no one is telling
the truth, the full truth about this treatment.
Now, if you've been watching this show last
week, the week before, I've been telling you
about many possible treatments for coronavirus
for a while now.
One of those that I told you about already
is chloroquine, possibly combined with the
antibiotic Zithromax, a zero myson.
Now, I know you're probably saying an antibiotic
to treat a virus.
We'll get to that.
OK, let's table that for a moment.
Donald Trump caught wind of this.
And remember that this is just one possible
treatment and he has been propagandizing around
it.
Trump tweeted over the weekend, Hydroxy chloroquine
and as they throw myson taken together, have
a real chance to be one of the biggest game
changers in the history of medicine.
Very hyperbolic.
The FDA has moved mountains.
Hopefully they will both hydrochloride.
Rocsi, chloroquine works better with zero
myson, according to a journal, be put in use
immediately.
People are dying.
Move fast.
God bless everyone.
Trump also got into an argument with a reporter
about it after mentioning it during a press
conference.
Take a look.
Drug called chloroquine.
And some people would add to it.
Hydroxy hydroxy calorically chloroquine or
hydroxide chloroquine.
Now, this is a common malaria drug.
It's also a drug used for strong arthritis.
Somebody has pretty serious arthritis.
Also uses this in a somewhat different form.
But it is known as a malaria drug.
It's been around for a long time and it's
very powerful.
And then arguing with the reporter about it,
about the possible therapies yesterday.
Mr. President, you said that they were for
immediate delivery.
Immediate.
We heard ordering.
Yes.
We have millions of units ordered bearer's.
One of the companies, as you know, big company,
very big, very great company.
Millions of units are ordered.
And we'll see what happens.
We're going to be talking to the governors
about it.
And the FDA is working on it right now.
The advantages that it has been prescribed
for a totally different problem, but it has
been described for many years and everybody
knows the levels of of the negatives and the
positives.
But I will say that I am a man that comes
from a very positive school when it comes
to, in particular, one of these drugs.
And we'll see how it works out.
Peter, I'm not I'm not saying it will, but
I think that people may be surprised by the
way there would be a game changer.
But we're going to know very soon.
But but we have ordered millions of units.
It's being ordered from there.
And there is another couple of companies also
that that do it.
Dr. Fouchier said there is no magic drug for
coronavirus right now, which you would agree,
I guess, on this as well.
I think we only have a limited time.
I disagree.
Maybe.
And maybe less.
Maybe there is.
Maybe there isn't.
We have to see.
We're going to know.
Is it is it possible that your impulse to
put a positive spin on things, maybe giving
Americans a false sense?
No, I don't think so.
That's right.
I don't think so.
I think that I think it's got a pretty on
social obligation.
Look, it may work and it may not work.
And I agree with Dr..
What he said may work.
May not work.
I feel good about it.
Still, it is just a feeling, you know.
So the problem is that when Trump jumps in
like this, almost nobody gets it right.
That's the unfortunate reality.
You've got a ton of Trump ists who believe
this is the cure.
This is a game changer.
This is it.
That's not what the science says right now.
But I also got a lot of messages on Twitter
from anti-Trump guests, and I'm an anti-Trump
ist who have been tweeting me.
David, this is a total sham.
There's no promise whatsoever in this is the
treatment.
And Trump is a straight up lying.
So let's talk about the truth.
This is one course of treatment that's being
tested.
So far, it's been small scale tests.
I'll tell you about the larger test that's
starting.
There is enough promise with this treatment
that we need larger testing to be done.
Trump said the drug is approved to treat coronavirus.
It's not.
It is an FDA approved drug for malaria.
Using it on Corona virus would be an off-label
use.
It would be speculative.
It's not approved for coronavirus treatment,
but maybe it could be used under compassionate
use or in trials.
Possibly.
Okay.
There is a French doctor, DDA Rao, who did
a small non randomized trial with it.
But we need to understand the study that was
done.
The study showed excellent results.
It was a very small sample size.
It was not randomized and it was not blinded.
Now, why does this matter?
This is really important for a doctor and
say you have 40 patients with Corona virus,
you know, the patients ages, you know the
patient's underlying medical conditions.
So you as the doctor, could choose to try
the new treatment in this case, chloroquine
and a Zathura myson, you could say, I'm going
to give this to the patients that are likely
to do better anyway.
The patients with fewer symptoms, the patients
more likely to recover naturally anyway.
And you could do this consciously if you want
to skew the results.
You could also do it subconsciously.
This is why the tests need to be randomized
and blinded.
The patients that get the new treatment that's
being tested versus the standard treatment
or no treatment or a placebo.
They should be selected randomly and the doctor
should not know which patients are getting
which treatment.
In an ideal world, it would be double blind
where the patients also don't know if they
are getting the standard or the potential
new treatment.
That wasn't done.
It wasn't done with the chloroquine only treatment.
It wasn't done with the chloroquine plus as
it throw myson treatment.
So that that's why we can't judge much from
the study we have so far.
Number two, why an antibiotic for a virus?
It's important to understand the is--it throw
myson is not being used to kill bacteria.
It's being used because it's known to have
an anti-viral like effect on lung cells in
COPD patients, COPD, of course, of a respiratory
illness.
So that's why the is--it throw myson is being
used.
So is this enough to be promising?
Absolutely.
Along with many other ideas, is Trump overselling
it?
Of course.
Is Trump totally wrong about this as a likely
cure?
Yes.
It's way too early to say that.
The reason that it's dangerously irresponsible
for Trump to talk about this is a game changer
is that there are people, especially right
wingers, who are looking for any reason to
stop self-isolation or not to start it.
When Trump says, hey, this really looks like
it could be a game changer, you're probably
pushing people towards not behaving responsibly.
And that's why Trump shouldn't do it.
It has potential needs to be taxed, tested
extensively.
And that's all we can say right now.
Let's next talk about the major trial
that
is starting.